This was well earned it was my pleasure
I hope our paths cross again as do i oh and you
tell your people i wasn't the one that broke that
welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 video all about
boba fett his history and the easter eggs from
the episode i'm doing videos for all the season 2
episodes so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all them we'll do a new
disney plus membership giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all your
boba fett predictions for season 2 on the video so
obviously careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but we'll just start with the big
stuff and work our way down the list number five
is the mandalorian takes boba fett's armor from
cobb vanth they make a couple references to the
damage that it's sustained recently in historical
damage from the star wars movies and books
tell your people that i wasn't the one that did
that to the armor so there's a dent in the armor
from where boba fett got hit on jabba's sail barge
mando also hits him on his armor to the same place
where han solo hit him there's damage on his
helmet from cad bane and if you didn't watch
the clone wars cad bane also mentored boba fett
as a bounty hunter when he got a little bit older
boba fett appeared as a child during the events of
the clone wars dave filoni actually revealed back
at star wars celebration 2015 that there was going
to be this five episode arc where boba fett and
cad bain were traveling around together in future
episodes but that never wound up getting made they
did make a lot of the episodes that dave filoni
talked about for the clone wars season seven
but the cadbane boba fett stuff didn't make it in
because they were mostly focused on finishing the
bad batch episodes that they had already done work
on there were a bunch of uncompleted episodes when
the show was canceled they also just announced one
of the new animated series that they're doing is
based on those bad batch characters after
the events of the clone wars season seven
and then they also wanted to wrap up the ahsoka
storyline the darth maul storylines in the clones
storyline just telling the story of order 66 from
their perspective crossing over with the events
of revenge of the sith execute order 66. if you
haven't seen those episodes i did videos for those
they're on my channel they were fantastic but for
those of you asking after season one because there
were a lot of theories about who showed up at the
end of season one episode five now we know who
it was but there were a lot of people at the time
that thought it could also be cad bane because he
also wears the same type of spurs that you heard
jingling across the sand as he was walking up to
fanuc shan's body and for those of you wondering
dave filoni did reveal that the cad bang character
did survive the events of the clone wars and
eventually went on to serve the empire so he's
still alive during the events of the mandalorian
and could always show up on the series at some
point but number four big stuff as the mandalorian
rides across the twin suns sunset varies star wars
a new hope tamara morrison returns as boba fett
without his armor watching from a vantage point
in the same clothing that we saw him in from the
end of season 1 episode 5 now knowing that it was
him after all at the time the episode aired last
year i felt like that was what they were going
for like why else would you put the spurs on
the boots and make them jingle that way if you
didn't want people to think that it was boba fett
just like a classic gunslinger would the episode
was titled the gunslinger which at the time was
mostly a reference to the mandalorian toro and
mingnas fennec shand character but it was also a
clever reference to boba fett coming back because
he's a gunslinger and they always knew that they
were going to do him during season two his face
doesn't betray any emotion he's stone cold but
he's probably been monitoring cobb vanth this
whole time just waiting for an opportunity to take
his armor back and then all of a sudden the mando
and baby yoda show up so now he's following them
not only because he wants to take his armor back
but probably because baby yoda has also piqued his
curiosity and you have to remember that he's still
a bounty hunter he would know about the bounties
that had been out on mando and baby yoda in the
past as of episode 1 we don't really know if moff
gideon has an active bounty out on them right now
but i'll address boba fett potentially working
for moff gideon in a second because you have the
whole boba fett working for darth vader all the
references to empire strikes back it just implied
that eventually those three or four characters
including baby yoda will have a great gunslinger
standoff at some point in the series the good
the bad and the ugly if we're talking about big
western movies mando being the clint eastwood
character the good moff gideon the bad and boba
fett the ugly because now he's literally scarred
from the damage he sustained in the sarlacc pit
the city miles version of boba fett and for those
of you asking yes obviously it's possible that rex
could show up on the series because he's still
alive after the events of return of the jedi too
he would also be played by tamora morrison he
plays all the clones that's sort of the trick
of star wars he is the clone number three but how
did boba fett survive the sarlacc pit during the
episode the tuscan raiders explain how the crate
dragon species eats sarlacc and this particular
krait dragon ate this sarlacc and that's why it's
using its lair as its home also for a lot of you
that were wondering yes that whole crate dragon
part of the episode is directly ripped out of a
knights of the old republic mission that you go
on to get a crate dragon pearl jon favreau is
the one that wrote the episode so apparently he's
a huge fan of knights of the old republic because
this area this sarlacc pit is in close proximity
to where the jawas scavenged boba fett's armor
and found cobb vanth boba fett probably escaped
when the sarlacc he was in got eaten or was in the
process of getting eaten by a crate dragon that's
a big callback reference to a phantom menace where
qui-gon jinn says there's always a bigger fish
as a bunch of successively larger fish come along
eating the smaller fish and speaking of water
references underwater they're in the dune sea
and the crate dragon also travels underneath the
sand underneath the dune sea it doesn't absolutely
confirm that this particular sarlacc pit is the
exact one that boba fett escaped from but it could
have been the tusken raiders say that they've
been tracking this particular crate dragon for
generations following its cycles just following
it around as it moved about tatooine hunting
but it's implied that boba fett barely escaped
with his life lost his armor in the process of
the escape but the best scar armor being super
strong is what helped him survive in the sarlacc
for so long but because cobb vanth said that
he got boba fett's armor within a couple weeks
of the end of return of the jedi you also have to
assume that the jawa scavenged it right after the
events of return of the jedi so boba fett himself
wasn't in the sarlacc for that long number two big
question what will boba fett's storyline be other
than reclaiming his armor and becoming a bounty
hunter again maybe in trying to reclaim his armor
they'll try to redeem the character after his poor
showing in return of the jedi in the hilarious way
he went out there was this whole joke about return
of the jedi in the fandom that he's meant to be
the most fearsome bounty hunter in the galaxy
they hype him up all through empire strikes back
you have that crazy ending with han solo going
into the carbonite then they hilariously take
boba fett out in a funny way in the sarlacc pit
at the very beginning of return of the jedi
and that's the last you hear the character
like well i guess he wasn't so badass after all
part of what they did during season 2 episode 1
was try to redeem the tuscan raider characters
like no they're not exactly the way that the
movies have portrayed them in the past they're way
cooler than you thought that they were so i feel
like that's what they're doing with the boba fett
character during season two possibly season three
and other seasons is try to show you why he's
the most fearsome bounty hunter in the galaxy
you also have the idea of real mandalorians versus
fake mandalorians with that whole cobb vanth twist
in the episode the way he took his helmet off so
quickly in the mando's insistence that part of
their code states that only real mandalorians have
the right to wear that armor john favreau himself
describes the boba fett character as not a true
mandalorian in the context of the star wars movies
in his history just someone who wears mandalorian
armor and doesn't necessarily follow their code
so i feel like that's the biggest teaser he could
give you for a huge mandalorian versus boba fett
fight at some point during the series whether or
not it happens during season 2 or season 3 remains
to be seen but whatever they do with the boba fett
character in terms of painting him as a villain
or an antagonist during season two i do like the
idea that they eventually want him to reclaim his
quote-unquote honor as he's reclaiming his armor
so it's possible that eventually if they don't
turn him into a crazy big villain in the future
of the series he'll also try to reclaim some of
his heritage technically as a genetic mandalorian
because jango fett at one time was a mandalorian
but then he got kicked out so technically boba
fett couldn't call himself a mandalorian at this
point in the series you also have the idea that
tomorrow morrison is getting a little bit older
so it's a little harder for him to film those
epic boba fett level action sequences that you
would want to see happen but that's why you would
eventually give him the armor back so that when
he wears it and then goes off the chain you could
put a stunt person anybody you want in the costume
underneath the helmet and just have him do the
voice over parts so you get your epic boba fett
fight scenes with the mandalorian i feel like all
the cobb van mando team-up scenes during episode
one are a good teaser for what that might be
like so if cobb vanth has only had the armor
for a couple years and he's already this good
with it think about how boba fett is going to
be when he gets his armor back i also want to
see tamara morrison put that helmet on for the
first time just to see the look on his face when
he gets his armor back the number one what about
ahsoka where is ahsoka tano if all the major news
sites were reporting rosario dawson had been cast
to play her in the last year well a lot of you may
have noticed that dave filoni wrote and directed
season 2 episode 5 he's the person that created
the ahsoka character during the clone wars series
with george lucas one of the rumored temporary
working titles for an episode in season two was
quote unquote the sorcerer which is a reference to
the jedi that the armor and the mandalorian make
they were really big about including
a lot of that dialogue in the season 2
trailer just letting you know we will eventually
see some jedi this season or people who used to
be jedi because technically ahsoka isn't a jedi
but i'll be doing more mandalorians season 2 and
star wars bonus videos next week leave all your
requests and big questions in the comments below
congratulations jay knight you're the giveaway
winner for my last big star wars video
everyone click here for my full mandalorian season
2 episode 1 video and everyone click here for my
new thor 4 marvel avengers video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!